cardon
[musique]
de 16 bombes bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle internet une chaîne de chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle think i love you
et nous diffusons en direct sur internet
comment allez vous qui êtes vous est-ce
que vous pouvez vous vous présenter
succinctement la merci de me recevoir je
suis avocat au barreau de paris
j'ai une activité dominante en droit
pénal je
suis un avocat qu'on pourrait qualifier
d' engager quel type de dossier vous
avez vous avez été amené à gérer quel
type de d'affaires alors
c'est très divers et puis quand on
vieillit évidemment ça évolue j'ai
fait du terrorisme j'ai fait du pénal de
rue je fais maintenant un peu plus de
pénal d affaire de pénal du travail du
pénal de la concurrence je défends aussi
souvent des confrères qui sont attaqués
je vous aurais eu 47 ans comme nouveau
venu alors
ça va vous surprendre mais je ne sais
surtout mon épouse qui regarde ça je
pense que je ne vous mens pas en vous
disant que c'est entre dix et quinze
mille euros par mois doubi glouton
depuis 20 ans je suis avocat pourquoi
vous avez décidé de juin c'est une
vocation très
tôt je me rappelle une conversation avec
mes parents un vers 10-11 ans l'oeuvre
de justice m'a toujours séduit jeu
j'hésitais entre la magistrature et le
barreau et je me rappelle très bien une
conversation avec mon père critiques
dans la magistrature il fallait obéir et
donc j'ai su que je serais avocat c'est
un problème pour vous nourrir oui c'est
un problème non pas l'obéissance qui
peut être très belle dans d'autres états
que celui d'avocat chez les religieux un
abandon de sa souveraineté personnel
librement consentis l'obéissance
systématique sans réflexion oui ça
m'exaspère moi j'ai besoin d'adhérer
avant de m'engager là
vous vous présentez ou pato n'a c'est
quoi le bonheur qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un bâtonnier
qu'est ce que c'est qu'il me tenu alors
pour vous répondre faudrait savoir ce
que c'est que la communauté des avocats
la communauté des avocats c'est une
profession réglementée doté d'une
déontologie un
avocat c'est quelqu'un qui aide un
justiciable soit se défendre soit montée
en puissance sur ses projets nous sommes
des [raclement de gorge] professions
libérales réglementées et nous sommes
organisés en ordre professionnel pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée à paris nous
existons comme ordre professionnel
depuis treize 144 et
le bâtonnier c'est celui qui a en charge
cette communauté pendant deux ans et sa
charge sa charge de travail sa fonction
sa fonction en tant que telles que alors
c'est un plein-temps avantage we made
you we all avantage c'est d'abord d'être
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être volontaire
l'avantagent
c'est que vous êtes dans ma conception
de cette charge l'avocat des avocats
pendant deux ans et ça c'est très
enthousiasmant d'évoquer en france 60
min combien de vocations paris mais un
peu moins de 30000 28 1976
ensuite les inconvénients de bachar je
sais que c'est un plat temps donc vous
quittez votre cabinet pour vous
consacrer exclusivement à la défense des
intérêts de vos confrères qu'est-ce
que comment je conçois drôle et bien
tout simplement comme
[raclement de gorge] un avocat le fait
pour le justiciable la la clientèle
unique c'est le barreau et bien c'est
servir les intérêts du barreau les
intérêts du gant ou sont menacés en ce
moment oui on
va reboucler la boucle avec qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un avocat un avocat c'est
quelqu'un qui est doté d'une déontologie
la déontologie la première règle c'est
le secret professionnel
c'est à dire concrètement que ça veut
dire c'est que vous rentrez dans le
bureau d'un avocat vous vous confier à
lui est ce que vous dites ne sortira pas
ces marmots rien aujourd'hui
le législateur menace le secret
professionnel les institutions
internationales avec leur culte
incantatoire de la transparence menace
le secret professionnel je vais vous
donner un exemple dernière conférence de
l'om est à
l'ordre du jour une motion pour que le
secret professionnel ne soit pas
opposable en matière de santé publique
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
les
consultations délivrés par les avocats
en matière de santé publique peuvent
être saisis pourquoi
pourquoi on admettrait une atteinte au
secret professionnel on vous dit c'est
la santé publique très bien c'est une
bonne prise d'otage affective mais
est-ce que la consultation d'un avocat
vient contrarier les enjeux de santé
publique non un avocat il est là pour
conseiller en droit traduire
juridiquement les prétentions de son
client si son client ne peut plus tout
lui dire parce qu'il a peur que demain
sa position soit mise sur la place ça ne
sert plus à rien ça veut dire qu'on a
des conversations mondaines ça veut dire
qu'on évacue l'humanité de l'oeuvre de
justice si le secret professionnel n'est
pas là pour protéger le justiciable ça
veut dire que l'intérêt même de se
confier qui à la base de la relation
entre un avocat et un justiciable est
rompu
le tort de la profession pour aller au
bout de notre réflexion c'est qu'elle
réagit de façon corporatiste aux
atteintes au secret professionnel
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on fait les
avocats ont fait des colloques entre
nous et résultat la perception quant à
l'opinion publique c'est que en réalité
nous prônons le secret professionnel
comme un droit comme un privilège
propres à une corporation
c'est une vision complètement obsolète
des choses il faut convaincre l'opinion
publique et pour ça il faut rappeler ce
que c'est que le secret professionnel
le secret professionnel c'est un devoir
qui s'impose à l'avocat et c'est un
droit pour le justiciable un devoir qui
s'impose à l'avocat de ne jamais
dévoiler ce qui s'est dit dans son
cabinet comment vous dire le secret
professionnel et quand vous avez des
objets connectés comment il ya par
exemple une enceinte connectés qui coûte
que vous racontez quand il ya par
exemple des
écoutes [raclement de gorge] sur
certaines personnes et que l'avocat se
retrouve dans la boucle des coûte vous
avez des choses des viviers là dessus ah
oui bien sûr alors d'abord la première
chose c'est la vigilance de l'avocat
vis-à-vis de lui-même il le doit à la
personne qui vient se confier à lui
alors ça peut être l'ancien de connecter
évidemment dans un bureau ça me paraît
mal venu c'est aussi faire attention à
sa propre communication sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya des commentaires de
certains confrères que je trouve
parfaitement déplacé on regarde et du
second optionnel et de l'indépendance de
l'avocat sur
des affaires qui viennent de plaider sur
l'ambiance d'une juridiction sur les
déclarations d'un prévenu à l'audience
ensuite [grognement]
la deuxième partie de votre question
c'était les
écoutes téléphoniques la loi
renseignements attendait incroyable
délirant j'ai été le seul à réagir à
l'époque je vais vous raconter comment
ça s'est passé pour vous voyez ici c'est
sympa alors d'abord le l'immense délire
de la loire enseignement c'est
l'institutionnalisation des m6 catchers
si quelques jours ouais merci de me
reprendre sur la bonne
formulation qu'est ce que c'est ça
permet de capter les données dans un
endroit donné parce que l'atteinte au
secret professionnel s'est pas seulement
écouter un avocat qui parle avec son
client c'est déjà savoir
que l'avocat et le client sont en
relation c'est déjà une atteinte au
secret professionnel et c'est ce que
permettent ces appareils alors
il ya eu quelque chose de très
intéressant comme la loi renseignement
était en cours d'élaboration à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont écouté
très poliment les représentants de la
profession est donné les assurances
qu'il n'y aurait rien résultat comme
d'habitude par un amendement parallèle
ils ont voulu réintroduire la
possibilité d'écouter les avocats on a
été prévenus par une consoeur qui
s'appelle russian et ac qui travaillait
en étroite collaboration avec sergio
coronado qui était un des seuls députés
à travailler réellement sur le texte et
à être soucieux du respect des libertés
individuelles qui est un des combats que
je prône résultat
nous on a été prévenus grâce à cet ami
et on a pu ré intervenir pour protéger
le secret postal des avocats les
médecins n'ont pas été prévenus par une
amie et eux ils sont fait avoir
puisqu'ils ont cru à la parole du
représentant de la commission des lois
qui a dit qu'on serait vigilant c'est un
combat de tous les instants de tous les
instants dans une société qui prône la
transparence sans savoir ce que ça veut
dire par souci de communication sais
même pas par souci d'éthique mots c'est
ça que je trouve très remarquable
l'atteinte
au secret professionnel elle est
systématique
chaque proposition de loi donne à un
vecteur un médium pour essayer de porter
atteinte il faut le défendre parce que
c'est la liberté de chaque citoyen qui
est menacée à chaque fois qu'on vient
corrompre le caractère sacré du secret
professionnel comment vous expliquer
cette cette
continuité dans la demande
de mieux vous écoutez de de mieux
entendre sa population si je peux être
cynique à ce point là c'est à dire
comment vous expliquer la position de
l'état pourquoi l'état demande sous
steam je
pense d'abord que l'état déteste les
corps intermédiaires et
que les avocats dans le top ten de cette
discrimination sont assez bien placé
pourquoi parce que les avocats n'hésite
pas à dénoncer a dénoncé par exemple
pour prendre des lois récentes a dénoncé
le glissement des dispositions
spécifiques à l'état d'urgence dans le
droit commun là aussi atteinte aux
libertés publiques et aux libertés
individuelles
on vous place tout ça sous le slogan de
l'impératif sécuritaire et on risque
exactement mais en réalité sont des
atteintes quotidiennes il ya eu déjà
pendant l'état d'urgence des exemples
formidables je veux dire pendant la coop
21 on interdisait des écologistes de se
réunir sous prétexte de l'état d'urgence
pendant l'euro 2016 on interdisait à des
supporters qui étaient assignés à
résidence donc si vous voulez ça devient
prétexte à quoi à une police
administrative c'est un moyen simple
qu'on donne à l'état de prendre des
mesures arbitraires et liberticide aux
dépens de la liberté d'aller et de venir
par commodité ça n'a rien à voir avec
des impératifs de sécurité et encore
moins de lutte anti terroriste
d'empêcher des militants écologistes de
se rendre où ils veulent et des
supporters de football de faire de même
donc
vous l'interrogiez sur le fait que la
transparence est l'impératif sécuritaire
deviennent envahissants moi je vous dis
c'est une dialectique facile une
communication facile et je le dis
d'autant plus simplement que je n'ai
aucun mépris pour les citoyens qui se
sentent en insécurité
je pense qu'il faut les écouter mais je
pense qu'il ne faut pas les leurs et et
que la principale la sécurité elle
réside dans l'abandon de nos valeurs et
nos valeurs c'est d'abord la liberté si
devant la liberté i could outre quels
autres valeurs on peut prôner un
principe
galvaudé mais j'ai été ravi de lire une
décision récente du conseil
constitutionnel qui a consacré ce
principe c'est le principe de fraternité
c'est à dire qu'on n'entame pas la
relation humaine par la défiance c'est à
dire que il ya un principe de fond c'est
celui de l'altérité c'est de reconnaître
en l'autre à n'égale de reconnaître que
nous sommes tous des frères humains qui
occuperont la terre à un moment donné et
qu'une réflexion globale n'est pas à
exclure et qu'il faut aborder évidemment
avec prudence les enjeux évidemment les
réfléchissant mais on ne les
réfléchissant passe sous l'angle
exclusif de la sécurité pourquoi d'abord
parce que c'est un marché la sécurité il
ne faut pas être trompée c'est un marché
qui génère beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui
on le voit je vais vous donner un
exemple concret le nouveau tribunal de
grande instance de paris c'est un
endroit qui a mille
avantage il eût été encore plus glorieux
ci s'était accompagnée d'une révolution
des cultures et des mentalités mais en
tout cas il a le mérite d'exister cela
dit avec des règles de sécurité
délirante
délirante j'ai eu la chance de
l'entretien avec le président du
tribunal je lui ai demandé qui avait
donné ses instructions à l'architecte
m'a dit ça nous dépasse nous
on en fait la promotion mais ça nous
dépasse c'est la technostructure et la
technostructure qu'est-ce qu'elle
négocie en réalité quant à la pose d
artifice de sécurité parce que ça
n'empêche rien je vais venir dans un
instant elle impose le fait qu'un budget
quel budget de la nation soient
consacrés à ses propres entreprises qui
vendent de la sécurité voilà c'est une
question parfaitement commercial et
c'est si vrai que c'est dans le déni de
l'intérêt des particuliers donc des
personnes autre valeur qui doit être au
centre des réflexions que il y a une
semaine un mineur s'est vu refuser
[grognement]
le statut de mineur isolé l'audience
avait lieu au quatrième étage il a tenté
de se suicider dans ce bâtiment
extrêmement sécurisé la première
personne qui doit être protégé c'est le
justiciable et ben non il est idiot
kinobe no way un burkinabé qui s'est
jetée du 4e étage deuxième
réflexion extrêmement intéressante que
ça a provoqué qui à mon avis est
parfaitement symbolique concomitamment
au drame
le président du tribunal de grande
instance tenait à une réunion avec ses
homologues pour leur vanter la qualité
de l'architecturé du bâtiment et leur
dire que c'était l'avenir de tous les
tribunaux de france il
ne s'est pas déplacé ce sont des avocats
ce sont d'autres justiciables et les
personnels de l'ordre des avocats qui se
sont précipités au secours de ce jeune
malheureux et
aucun magistrat n'est descendu les
remercier personnes
il ya une vague cellule de soutien
psychologique qui a été mise en place si
vous voulez voilà le drame humain voilà
à quoi conduit ses bâtiments autre
délire
architectural dans ce bâtiment la
circulation est organisé pour que les
avocats et les magistrats ne puisse pas
se rencontrer est pire que les
justiciables ne puisse pas non plus
rencontré les magistrats et ça conduit à
une déclaration moi qui m'a laissé
pantois madame prévost-desprez l'autre
matin sur france inter a déclaré ce
tribunal est formidable rendez vous
compte dans l'ancien palais de justice
on pouvait croiser les avocats et les
prévenus de nos audiences écoutez bien
ce qui nous obligeait à expliquer nos
décisions vous
voyez à quoi on en vient cette
compartimentation symbolique en fait
c'est le refus de motiver les décisions
décision
est une décision qu'il est comprise une
bonne décision est une décision qui est
comprise je vois que vous avez relu le
mariage de figaro vous savez quand le
juge à la fin
d es figaro c'en est assez de sa justice
je vais en corriger une seconde en vous
motive mon arrêt tout juge qui s'y
refusent est un grand ennemi des lois il
ya des avantages quand même dans ce
nouveau tribunal ou pas du tout la
question très honnête il ya un avantage
pour
les magistrats qui n'est pas négligeable
c'est la qualité du travail c'est clair
que les espaces de travail et est
beaucoup trop restreint dans l'ancien
palais moi j'étais favorable à une
extension en
prenant la préfecture de police de paris
et en restant au coeur de la cité là
aussi c'était il ya une question
symbolique de l'accès au droit le budget
du ministère de financement français
combien le budget des ministères des
finances le pardon le budget de l'eau
budget du ministère de la justice je
vous repose il est il est en
augmentation prévue mais si vous voulez
parler de la question budgétaire du
projet de loi je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va être plus parlant que le
budget lui-même sont ces affectations ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on est au
24e rang européen en terme d'argent
dédié par habitant la grande-bretagne
150 euros l'allemagne 135 euros la
france 75 euros par habitant voyez il ya
quelque chose qui ne marche pas sans
compter que en plus notre justice est
gratuite c'est un de ces grands mérites
alors que si vous prenez l'exemple de la
grande bretagne l'accès au droit est
payant et malgré ce handicap
le budget alloué à la justice par
habitant parce que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut raisonner spa par grande masse est
le double du budget qui consacre les
français voyez là dessus il ya un retard
immense vous savez que le nombre de
magistrats a à peine évolué depuis 1945
alors
que notre population monte
fortement sensiblement de 50% ou alors
question d'internet pourquoi les avocats
ne parviennent pas à aller dans le même
sens contrairement aux notaires et aux
experts comptables
parce
qu'on est des chats on est vous savez
nous on est un village gaulois un avocat
c'est d'abord un esprit individuel il ya
une deuxième raison parce que
l'internaute à as tout à fait raison la
deuxième raison c'est que nous sommes
des professions libérales alors que les
notaires sont des officiers ministériels
mais ce qui m'intéresse
les causes donc peuvent être analysés
comme ça c'est qu'il ya une liberté
d'expression chez nous qui favorise la
dispersion et la dilution de la parole
il faudra y travailler faudra y
travailler mais pas en imposant les
choses faudra y travailler par un une
oeuvre de conviction mais pour répondre
directement il a d'autant plus raison
participation aux élections des notaires
100% participation
donc c'est la légion romaine
participation aux élections des avocats
20% c'est le village gaulois avec ce
qu'il est sympathique mais ce qu'il a de
faibles
si on veut conclure par la guerre des
gaules faut nous organiser faut nous
organiser mieux faut professionnaliser
notre influence je vais vous donner un
exemple les notaires y passe 3d créé par
an
nous on en passe zéro je vais vous
donner un autre exemple le froid me
projet de loi justice dont vous venez de
m'entretenir tout le monde est d'accord
pour réformer la justice en france
tout le monde critique
le projet de loi actuel est souvent à
raison mais je pose une question
concernant les avocats où est le projet
de loi des avocats laquelle
de nos institutions représentatives au
lieu de subir le texte a décidé de
prendre la question en amant et de
soumettre des propositions au
gouvernement et à l'assemblée nationale
personne personne parce qu'on gouverne à
courte vue c'est vrai qu'on ne fait pas
de prospective on ne sait pas qui sera
l'avocat dans 10 ans est
de même en matière d' influence nous
sommes faibles nous sommes faibles de
notre faute parce que nous ne
travaillons pas ou pire nous pêchons par
orgueil nous pensons qu'étant avocat
nous pouvons simplement par talent
convaincre là les pouvoirs publics mais
nous commettons une grave erreur nous ne
parlons pas la même langue
vous organisez pas pareil y'a pas de
fallon jeu pas de phalanges d'un book
oui ça c'est plutôt heureux qu'ils aient
pas de phalanges d'avocat si on doit
raisonner en termes de résonance
historique
ce
qui est sûr ce qui est sûr c'est que
nous on a on
a par contre une réelle influence
pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'on est un poste
d'observation privilégié de la société
française comment la société française
en ce moment je pense qu'elle est tendue
moi je suis très intéressé par le
mouvement des gilet jaune très
intéressés donc vous acceptez cette
digression généraux d'activé le
le débat à moi je suis fasciné par
l'incapacité de l'état à faire face à
des nouvelles formes de contestation
comme s'il fallait que le format d'une
contestation soit près établi presque
iso normes et vous voyez pour qu'on
puisse y répondre je pense typiquement
que la profession d'avocat un rôle à
jouer que dirige du gouvernement alors
contre les dérives évidemment si vous
voulez par exemple les mesures
liberticides d'interdiction
de se rassembler ou de manifester qui
sont en plus sanctionnée par le code
pénal mais
aussi pour apaiser la situation pour
essayer d'en sortir par le haut qui
mieux que les avocats connaît les règles
de la médiation qui mieux que les
avocats est habitué à faire face à de
nouveaux enjeux à de nouvelles formes de
poser les questions
nous on est en contact avec toutes les
strates de la population
les avocats sont tous prêts à engager
une médiation gouvernement gilet jaune a
organisé la triangulation de la parole
la façon dont chacun va pouvoir exposer
ses enjeux ses contraintes ses envies
c'est pas du tout utopique que les liens
que l'état accepte parce qu'il est en
conflit d'intérêts la l'état il peut pas
être à la fois partie est juge de
l'opportunité des revendications vous
avez lu les indications des
revendications je les ai trouvés très
diffuse mais c'est précisément ce qui
est intéressant un peu la liste de noël
dont c'est la liste de noël mais
pourquoi parce qu'on ne les a pas aidé à
rassembler et malgré cette liste de noël
donc qui convoque le père noël donc
l'utopie ce n'est pas du tout utopique
les préoccupations qui sont portées
c'est pas utopique dans un dans un
milieu de guerre économique de
mondialisation et d'erreurs du pouvoir
d'achat ouais mais l'érosion du pouvoir
d'achat certes mais l'europe va
pouvoir écouter les revendications des
gilets jaunes tard mais je pense que
c'est pas le problème des gilet jaune
s'ils ne sont pas audibles je pense qu
il faut d'abord avoir envie d'écouter
quelqu'un donc pour qu'ils soient
audibles est ce que la commission
européenne vous donne l'impression
d'avoir envie d'écouter les gilet jaune
les avocats vous moi ce
n'est pas organisé pour c'est une
technostructure une technostructure plus
elle fonctionne de façon autonome et
sans perturbation démocratique du
processus de décisions mieux elles se
portent ces salles immenses question qui
est posée actuellement c'est comment
porter la revendication pour devenir
audible maintenant qu'ils aient des
enjeux budgétaires et des contraintes
budgétaires ça n'échappe à personne non
plus heureusement qu'il ya des
fonctionnaires qui sont là pour vérifier
l'affectation des fonds mais ce que nous
nous demandons à ses fonctionnaires
comme à tout service public de manière
générale ces deux précisément ne pas
oublier qu'ils sont au service ils sont
pas au service de leur structure ils
sont au service de tous voilà donc c'est
comme l'enjeu sécuritaire dont on
parlait tout à l'heure il s'agit pas
d'auto nourrir un système pour l'aider à
devenir autosuffisants et prendre son
indépendance par rapport à la mission
sacrée qui est la sienne qui est très
belle c'est celle de servir et
il ya des gens particulièrement sensible
à la mission de service c'est les
avocats c'est un souci peut-être nous et
les crs attendait les crs dans cette
affaire c'est eux les vrais prolétaires
c'est pas le crs et moi que je mets en
cause c'est celui qui lui donne l'ordre
de charger le crs il est peut-être
beaucoup plus précarisé que celui qu'il
a en face de lui c
ça qui est affreux c'est la manipulation
de la base et le fait d'ériger les uns
contre les autres et pour contre des
pauvres ouais mais c'est ça à quoi vous
assister là vous assister à ça et
c'est là qu'il faut être très vigilant
parce que le but c'est la paix sociale
c'est pas de souffler sur les braises
c'est d'arriver à une forme d'harmonie
si le terme n'était pas aussi galvaudé
et
il devrait se méfier parce que le crs
après avoir été humilié à un barrage ou
pendant une manifestation
il rentre chez lui le dimanche il
déjeune en famille et il doit subir à
nouveau les conversations on lui demande
de rendre des comptes sur ce qu'il a
fait mais qu'est ce qui va faire lui il
va expliquer qui reçoit des ordres donc
ça va nourrir encore plus leurs
sentiments alors qu'est ce qu'on veut on
veut une société de choc et de violence
et de ressentiment on veut une société
dans ce pays qui donnent des leçons au
monde entier où on veut une société où
au moins la parole circule quand
l'ordre qu'on leur donne et n'est pas un
mot d'ordre est le devoir du cnrs vous
savez qu'il ya une jurisprudence établit
un cc la vieille question des cerveaux
et des fusils la
première question qui doit se poser
c'est de savoir si l'ordre est légal ou
non avant de savoir s'il est légitime ou
non là
il n'y a pas d'ordre illégal 1 tout est
fait dans les formes est-ce qu'il est
légitime ou non là le crs doit
travailler en conscience retenir
sa matraque mais c'est son problème que
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est le jour
pardonnez moi je vais peut être vous
choquer c'est le jour où ils vont
retenir leurs matraques parce que ça
veut dire qu'on sera très mal ça veut
dire qu'on sera au bord de la guerre
civile parce que c'est là que ces
questions se posent c'est dans un climat
insurrectionnel que se posent cette
question respect de la chaîne de
commandement au période
insurrectionnelle ouais c'est ça la
bonne question c'est un exercice qui a
été fait il ya six ou sept ans je
compare la préfecture de police de paris
d'accord et alors qu'est ce que ça va
donner cette expérience j'ai pas eu de
retour depuis
et moi j'ignorais l'existence de cette
expérience je vous la vous c'est une
vieille question endroit c'est pour ça
que je vous disais que c'est une bonne
question mais
on ne peut pas non plus s'étonner du
fait que les forces de sécurité qui nous
protège également un est
un souci d'efficacité moi ça ne me
choque pas vous
senti une guerre
civile venir ou pas du tout pas du tout
juin parce que je pense qu'on est dans
une société de consommation je
crois beaucoup plus à l'implosion molle
et gelard doute tout autant je
pense que l'essentiel
c'est de consommer et
temps vous pouvez consommer et jouer les
enjeux sociétaux ne vous préoccupe pas
plus que ça donc je crois beaucoup plus
ça au fait que ça va s'écraser mollement
plutôt qu'à des barricades qu'ils vont
s'ériger dans les rues de paris avec un
recul des libertés fondamentales avait
clairement le
deal général là c'est quoi ces on vous
donne la sécurité vous donnez vous nous
donnez votre liberté celle
échanges à
la taiwanaise sécurité
et consommation et plus de libertés
individuelles par
ailleurs hong kong le problème c'est de
savoir où va se situer la majorité et le
problème c'est de savoir comment se
forment les majorités
selon quels critères et est ce que le
consentement à à ce contrat finalement
que propose certaines écoles étatiques
est-ce que l'adhésion à ce contrat est
libre et éclairé ou pas donc
si cléry est ce que les médias et clairs
correctement le chemin de nos
concitoyens et ce que je pense pas que
les médias soient les seuls responsables
d'abord je pense que c'est torts
partagés peut-être que si on manifestait
plus d'appétit pour des séquences des
changes d'information de débats que nous
nous manifestons aujourd'hui c'est
tout l'intérêt de votre émission c'est
de donner le temps de s'expliquer
peut-être qu'ils auraient plus d'offres
en
contrepartie toujours
médias passent le responsable mais quand
même qu'aux responsables c'est
précisément la question des formats et
de la communication qui prime sur la
pensée moi je suis très frappé de voir à
quel point on favorise la réduction du
champ lexical et
quand on réduit la sémantique et bien on
réduit la pensée si on accepte de voir
la pensée réduite il ne faut pas
s'étonner que le postulat du débat soit
mal posée et que les gens agissent d'une
façon primitive mais
vous savez lire ouais primitive primaire
primal tout ce que vous voulez je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus être dupe du
fonds de l'homme nous
avons une part de violence en nous je
voulais m'en en tant qu avocat pénaliste
je vous dis tout être humain a une part
non seulement de violence mais même deux
monstres ennuis l'avantagent
des états civilisés l'avantagent d etat
de droit c'est précisément que l'homme
accepte de dominer ses impulsions et ses
instincts violent on est toujours dans
un état de droit ah oui je crois mais
avec la déviance de la délinquance en
col blanc la mère de la délinquance en
col blanc c'est une forme de délinquance
c'est pas ça à l'état de droit l'état de
droit c'est l'état qui garantit à
l'individu de pouvoir se défendre
whistleblower
ils peuvent se défendre et qu'est ce que
c'est les fonctionnaires et
ils peuvent mal se défendre aujourd'hui
le mérite ça on peut quand même pas le
nier le mérite c'est qu'ils aient une
réflexion les législatives pour leur
octroyer un statut de protection alors
aujourd'hui ce statut est très
insuffisant il y a d'ailleurs une part
d'arbitraire dans le fait de savoir qui
a le droit de bénéficier du statut de
lanceurs d'alerté ou de ne pas en
bénéficier mais vous pouvez pas nier qu
aujourd'hui le législateur à 1 n'a pas
mépriser le phénomène des lanceurs
d'alerté
et 2 essaye de leur octroyer un statut
de protection 3 est ce que ce système
est parfait non quatre et ils
perfectible oui 5 les avocats sont à la
disposition du législateur pour l'aider
à le perfectionner au
[rires]
courage le secret des affaires ouais je
suis bien est ce que c'est bien je vais
vous dire c'est pas si mal parce que
c'est une problématique proche de
proches de la de la préoccupation du
secret professionnel le secret
professionnel c'est sacré ça doit pas
servir de prétexte au secret des
affaires mais réfléchissons
de seconde est ce que vous créez un
brevet vous ne bénéficiez pas du secret
des affaires qu'est-ce qui se passe les
initiatives et le progrès sont frustrés
bon et de toute façon quelles que soient
les lois qui protègent le secret des
affaires en creux dans votre question si
je la perçois mal coupé moi je perçois
une forme d'ironie de façon de dire que
le secret de fer est un moyen simple
pour procéder aux pires turpitudes en
pleine impunité mais admettez quand même
avec moi que de toute façon il y aura
toujours des gens pour violer les lois
qu'ils aient un statut de secret des
affaires ou pas et admettez avec moi
aussi dabs sur un terrain plus positif
que l'oat sanctionnant le secret des
affaires ou pas il y aura toujours des
gens vigilant animer des tic pour
dénoncer les comportement inadéquat donc
si vous voulez cette loi sur le secret
des affaires en réalité elle menace de
sanction totalement disproportionnée qui
va dénoncer quoi que ce soit mais en
parallèle à tous à la loi sur le secret
des sources a été renforcée l'immunité
des journalistes a été renforcée donc
que le texte ne soit pas équilibré je
vous le concède bien volontiers mais que
les conséquences du texte dans leurs
traductions juridictionnelle fasse peser
une menace tél
que nous pourrions considérer que nous
ne sommes plus dans un état de droit
pardonnez moi je ne suis pas d'accord le
critère de l'état de droit c'est
précisément que c'est un juge qui va
apprécier la proportionnalité de
l'intérêt pour le public d'avoir accès à
une information et
les intérêts lésés en face c'est si il
n'y avait plus de tiers et que la seule
autorité administrative était en mesure
de sanctionner qu'on sortirait de l'état
de droit mais l'indépendance de la
justice permettent
de garantir précisément qui a un tiers
de confiance le juge qui va apprécier le
choc entre la rétention de l'information
et la révélation de l'information
la justice va bien en fin de compte sous
macro mais c'est pas sous mac rond si
vous voulez moi je pense que les
problèmes dont souffrent d'autres
justice sont bien antérieures on peut
faire porter tous les péchés du monde à
ce projet de loi à ce gouvernement est
en général s'est porté par des majorités
qui ont été au gouvernement précédemment
qui n'ont pas du tout contribué à ce que
l'oeuvre de justice se perfectionne un
autre sujet qui me tient à coeur ce sont
les délais de jugement le temps de la
justice
est-ce que ça c'est compréhensible par
le justiciable bon mais si vous voulez
il n'y a pas eu plus de magistrats
nommés avant qu'il n'y en a aujourd'hui
il
ya un dilemne aujourd'hui énorme pour
les chefs de juridiction qui est
scandaleux c'est la gestion du flux des
dossiers déjà là cette seule ambition
laisse laisse rêveur et la motivation
des décisions on en revient c'est à dire
soit vous rendez justice rapidement mais
vous ne motive et pas vos décisions soit
vous motivez vos décisions et à ce
moment là il
faut pas vous étonner que la décision
soit tardive je vous donne un exemple
nos cousins l'italie choix
très affirmée de motiver les décisions
il
ya actuellement des décisions qui sont
rendus par la cour de cassation à propos
d'affaires qui ont débuté avant que je
ne prête serment il n'y a plus de 20 ans
voyez il ya peut-être un équilibre à
trouver parce
que plus de 20 ans après ça n'a plus de
sens va
sauter du coq à l'âne avocat c'est quoi
c'est un sacerdoce c'est c'est
une mission c'est un métier une vocation
c'est un état c'est un avocat c'est un
état les
avocats ont pour réputation de n'avoir
aucun scrupule à raconter n'importe quoi
pour obtenir gain de cause or elles sont
bien les seuls peut-on être un bon
avocat et entretenir un pur moral à la
vérité bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
déontologie la
déontologie précisément permet
d'encadrer la façon dont nous agissons
dire qu'un avocat est prêt à raconter
n'importe quoi c'est fonctionner par a
priori alors comme toutes les
caricatures c'est amusant mais ça ne
reflète pas la réalité et pour une
raison simple c'est que nous défendons
le justiciable que raconter n'importe
quoi c'est la garantie d'envoyer le
justiciable à 180 dans le mur ce
qui serait intéressant chez ceux qui
véhiculent cette rumeur ça serait tout
simplement qui viennent assister aux
audiences d'abord
ils verraient que dans les prises de
paroles ce qu'ils racontent n'importe
quoi ne sont pas uniquement les avocats
ça arrive aussi au ministère public ça
arrive aussi au dossier que dépose la
police voilà ça arrive qui est des gens
qui racontent n'importe quoi nous on est
là pour rétablir les choses celui qui a
la charge de l'objectivité totale de
l'audience c'est le juge nous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait valoir on fait valoir dans un
premier temps auprès
du juge qui a une règle du jeu qui
préside à la mise en cause d'autrui
c'est le respect de la procédure est
ce que la procédure a été respectée
c'est à dire est ce que on est en mesure
nous la société française de juger x ou
y ou est-ce que la procédure n'a pas été
respectée et à ce moment là les
conditions d'un procès équitable ne sont
pas réunies la deuxième chose
les faits sont contestés c'est de dire
pourquoi on est en mesure de contester
une vérité qui est celle de l' enquête
de police par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé et si les faits sont reconnus
c'est de demander au juge d'apprécier la
responsabilité exacte de celle ou celui
qu'on défend dans la commission de
l'infraction est
ce que cette oeuvre déjà
extraordinairement complexe et d'où le
besoin d'humanité des avocats c'est la
première ligne de notre serment en quoi
est-ce raconter n'importe quoi sans
compter que le juge se forger une
conviction comment à votre avis sur les
seuls dires des uns ou des autres ou à
partir des pièces que nous produisons
vous savez que l'argumentation d'un
avocat est soutenue par des conclusions
écrites conclusions écrites auxquelles
pour leur donner un caractère probant
nous adjoignons un certain nombre de
pièces ces pièces elle reflète la
réalité d'un dossier donc est ce que
vous croyez que vous pouvez bâtir une
oeuvre romanesque à partir du moment où
vous produisez des pièces et où vous
avez un dossier sur le bureau du juge si
je vous dis le petit grégory souffre est
conscient coin ça
c'est un grave dysfonctionnement
judiciaire c'est un grave
dysfonctionnement judiciaire avec une
responsabilité de l'état qu'on retrouve
dans d'autres dossiers comme outreau
c'est à dire d'abord l'âge du juge
d'instruction ou jaune est bien sûr trop
jeune et ça alors ça c'est un défaut
typiquement français c'est l'extrême
compartimentation entre les différents
métiers du droit très difficile pour un
avocat de devenir magistrat on parlait
tout à l'heure de la société anglo saxon
beaucoup plus fluide beaucoup plus
fluide donc beaucoup plus de façons de
penser et de réfléchir ensuite c'est
la mécanique judiciaire qui vise à
légitimer les erreurs initiales c'est à
dire vous savez que vous avez des moyens
de recours vous allez devant la chambre
de l'instruction et sert à des juges qui
jugent des juges et ne les des juges pas
donc
si vous voulez la machine judiciaire on
est là pour conforter la décision du
juge qu'il ait raison ou en l'espèce
avec le malheureux juge lambert qu'ils
aient tort donc
partant de là la machine ne broie pas
que ses victimes elle peut aussi
malheureusement transformé en victime
ses propres valait dur
on chante on pince encore du coq à l'âne
si je vous donne une bonne baguette
magique pour le bâtonnat vous changer
quoi votre plan d' attaques des choses
faire l'un d'un coup tac au tac alors
à vrai dire j'ai jamais réfléchit à
l'opportunité d'une baguette magique ou
d'un deus ex machina
la
première chose que je changerais c'est
l'extrême tension qui règne actuellement
entre les magistrats et les avocats y
compris et c'est ce que je trouve
détestable
les avocats dans leur mission
apparemment les plus humbles j'ai
beaucoup de confrères qui sont bousculés
à l'audience par des magistrats qui
sont peut-être exaspéré nerveusement par
d'autres choses mais ce n'était pas aux
avocats d'en payer le prix faut pas
oublier que nous concourons tous à
l'oeuvre de justice est
donc la première chose que je ferai
c'est faire disparaître les box vitré
faire disparaître les incivilités des
magistrats à l'audience et ce serait
remettre l'avocat au coeur de son rôle
citoyen civique sociale sociétale y
compris à l'audience dans une mission
très noble qui est celle de l'aide
juridictionnelle c'est à dire la défense
des plus démunis l'avocat est malmené
alors qu'il défend ce qui mérite le plus
d'attention et que l'avocat qui est déjà
fort mal et fort tard indemnisés qui
donne de lui de son art qui contribuent
en plus à la mission de service public
de la justice en ce faisant c'est à dire
qui était une des très belles figures de
notre barreau ce sont les confrères qui
se dédie à juridictionnelle
ce qu'ils aident à valoriser ce qu'est
un avocat dans sa mission la plus noble
et bien mon coup de baguette magique ça
serait pour qu'ils arrêtent de subir en
plus des tentative d'humiliation ou
d'intimidation qui à mon avis sont
parfaitement déplacées l'élargissement
de l'arbitrage est ce que c'est les
prémices d'une justice plus alors
très clairement c'est un phénomène plus
large de déjudiciarisation qu'est ce que
cherchent les gens qui vont chercher de
l'arbitrage sont pour des contentieux
des affaires très lourd ils viennent
chercher une justice où il ya moins
d'aléas juridique ils viennent chercher
une justice plus rapide et
par conséquent quelqu'un qui n'aura pas
peur de parler de sommes qui nous
échappe pas vous et morin
cette entreprise de déjudiciarisation
moi ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est sa
traduction dans le projet de loi actuel
vous savez qu'il ya d'autres modes de
règlement des conflits parce que
l'arbitrage pour des raisons juridiques
que je vous ai pas être c'est quand même
du judiciaire il ya une procédure c'est
les modes alternatifs de règlement des
différends c'est extraordinairement
intéressant par exemple dans cela la
médiation à laquelle nous visionnerons
allusion vous et moi au début de notre
entretien le projet de loi actuel
toujours dans son entreprise de
déjudiciarisation qui est une autre
source d'exaspération pour le citoyen
parce que ils arrivent à l'audience on
lui dit d'avoir recours à une médiation
on lui fait comprendre que s'ils
n'acceptent pas d'avoir recours à une
médiation le jugement ne va pas être
forcément rendu à son avantage il repart
et ressort il va perdre du temps et il
va dépenser de l'argent donc il ne
comprend pas pourquoi ils payent des
impôts pour qu'on lui apporte une
réponse en droit à une question qui pose
et qu'on l'obligé à avoir recours à une
médiation privé à côté qui va lui coûter
de l'argent alors qu'il en a déjà
dépensés à travers ses impôts je reviens
au projet de loi
aujourd'hui on veut rendre les modes
alternatifs de règlement des différends
un préalable obligatoire à l'action en
justice qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que l'état à une démarche
étrange mode alternatif c'est alternatif
à quoi à la justice d'états et
bien si l'état impose qu'on ait recours
aux
modes alternatifs de règlement des
différends dans son dans sa vaste
entreprise de déjudiciarisation ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il re
judiciarise les modes alternatifs de
règlement des différends voyez ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que non seulement
ont bloqué l'accès au juge mais en plus
et à mon avis c'est parfaitement avec
aux institutionnels on impose un
préalable obligatoire et ce qui est très
intéressant quand on est un connaît les
réflexes de notre vieux pays colbertiste
c'est que l'étape suivante moi je vous
parie que c'est l'état qui va créer un
établissement des modes alternatifs de
règlement des différends voilà donc vous
voyez la société idéale vers laquelle on
se dirige qu'ici on internet si je peux
demander qu'on me remonte un peu le
liste gernandt populiste super question
internet des conseils pour les futurs
militants manifestant arrêté on va dire
samedi on sait jamais pour les j ai
jaune signe barbecue qui organisait sur
les champs-elysées on parle de garde à
vue ou confiance d'un avocat commis
d'office totale confiance dans l'avocat
commis d'office le bon réflexe c'est
appeler un avocat mois par d'autres jeux
à l'ancien combattant mais il se trouve
qu'au départ on n'était que quatre à
militer pour la présence de l'avocat dès
la première heure de garde à vue et
nathalie schmele fabrice orlandi et
pierre-olivier sûr et moi et on est
assez content de ce qu'on a fait parce
qu'on a réussi à insuffler un travail de
mutualisation c'est
à dire quand on prenait des conclusions
nous systématiquement pour contester la
validité des
de toutes les procédures à partir du
moment où on nous avait refusé l'accès
dès la première heure de garde à vue et
il faut continuer ce combat aujourd'hui
pour que l'avocat est accès au dossier
dès la première heure de garde à vue
faut voir ce qu'on a entendu le fait
qu'on était complice de nos clients
c'est à dire toujours là priori de
l'avocat barreau du cuse et moi il n'a
pas pas plus que chez les policiers et
puis et puis on a mis en ligne on a fait
circuler nos conclusions et les
confrères et les concerts ont joué le
jeu c'est à dire qu'il nous renvoyait
nos conclusions perfectionner au fur et
à mesure des audiences au fur et à
mesure des arguments développés par les
juridictions pour rejeter nos
conclusions on les a amélioré par un
travail collectif qui a pris de
l'ampleur avec la conférence du stage
avec l'union des jeunes avocats et à la
faim à force de tout donner dès coups de
boutoir on est arrivé à ce que les
citoyens est enfin accès à ce droit qui
étaient en cours dans tous les autres
pays de l'union et accessoirement sans
que ça fasse contrairement à ce que nous
disait le ministre de la justice et le
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque en
rien diminuer le taux d'élucidation des
affaires en cours vous voyez ça permet
de jeter un éclairage cruel sur les
soupçons et les a priori et les
caricatures qui sont véhiculés sur les
avocats donc pour répondre concrètement
à la question de votre internaute un
appeler un avocat de totale confiance
dans les avocats commis d'office ils
sont formés pour intervenir au soutien
des intérêts et des droits des personnes
placées en garde à vue donc quelqu'un
qui se fait attraper qui
reste dans un mutisme le plus parfait il
attend son avocat mais évidemment tout
conseil comme ça et bien le deuxième
conseil entretenez vous avec votre
avocat et et suivait attentivement ses
conseils que vous décidiez d'avoir une
position militante ou pas suivez
attentivement ses conseils nous on est
là pour être aux côtés de la personne
mise en cause vos intérêts ne seront
jamais trahi parle donc posé tout sur la
table et on fera le tri ensemble encore
une qui sont internet on parle on garde
à vue ou parle pas ça ça dépend des
allées va vous avez le droit de
conserver le silence pour être franc en
général c'est plutôt une position de
caïds bon mais ça peut être une position
militante aussi ça peut être un parti
pris politique 1 ça peut être par
exemple je ne reconnais aucune
légitimité à l'état de juger par
conséquent on attend des parents plus à
ce que je collabore à votre jugement
mais sont des positions radicales moi je
pense que si on se fait choper dans une
manif il n'y a aucune raison ne pas
parler si vous voulez vous n'êtes pas
vous n'êtes pas monter au braquo vous
voyez bon donc pour moi garder le
silence dans ce type de dossier sauf
convictions philosophiques profonds de a
peu de sens mais surtout l' avantage de
l'assistance d'un avocat c'est que c'est
lui qui va vous dire au regard des faits
qui vous sont reprochés s'ils voulaient
n'y a pas de règle générale l'avantagent
de l'avocat ce qui va faire du sur
mesure va vous expliquer où est votre
intérêt en fonction des charges qui
pèsent sur vous et puis va vous suivre
pendant toute votre garde à vue
chaque fois que vous serez auditionné il
sera à vos côtés et il aura le droit à
la fin de l'audition de poser des
questions pareil en cas de confrontation
le délit de solidarité mais c'est
formidable ça fait qu'est ce que ça veut
dire délit de solidarité vous voyez où
on va passer rien
que le terme sissach correspondait pas
un drame humain moi me fait sourire le
principe de fraternité grâce au travail
d'henri leclerc puis de patrice spinosi
devant le conseil constitutionnel avec
les qpc nous on anime avec un certain
nombre de copains une association qui
s'appelle serment d'humanité qui vient
en aide est
venue limiter messana
délit de solidarité dans une société la
société française un
pays d'accueil qu'est
ce que ça veut dire rien
délit
de solidarité vous voyez ce que ça veut
dire la solidarité devient un délit je
ris jaune et c'était c'est formidable
d'un point de vue symbolique enfin jeu
chez ces gens qui sont obsédés par la
communication qu'on est simplement pensé
pouvoir produire un texte qui révèle un
délit de solidarité c'est hallucinant
cesser sa marque une dégénérescence des
esprits et de l' usage de la langue qui
est absolument bouleversant parce que ça
veut dire qu'on en vient à prendre des
décisions au mépris même de notre
identité nationale
nationale 2 français 2 français du pays
d'accueil il n'y a pas besoin de france
n est jamais le monopole de l'accueil
mais c'est une tradition que nous
revendiquons haut et fort tous les pays
ne la revendique pas autant que nous
nous on en a fait une des valeurs
fondatrices ça
renvoie à quelque chose de très amusant
dans la dans la phraséologie actuelle on
vous parle de roman national donc ça
veut dire que les valeurs que nous
portons son romanesque donc ça relève du
roman donc de la fiction bon
moi je propose que le caractère
délictuel de la solidarité ce soit lui
qui deviennent fictif pas la solidarité
aux questions ressoude du coq à l'âne
empreintes et adn peut tous refusé oui
vous pouvez refuser vous pouvez refuser
mais vous vous exposez au risque de
poursuites
alors il ya des matières où c'est devenu
incontournable
les délits et les crimes sexuels par
exemple pourquoi parce qu on constitue
des fichiers moi ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est le temps d'inscription
dans ses fichiers c'est la légalité de
ces fichiers c'est le fichage général en
tant qu'avocat ça m'interroge évidemment
beaucoup en termes de libertés
individuelles mais je vous dire le pire
c'est
que pour ce faire désinscrire d'un
fichier parce que vous savez que vous
pouvez pas être inscrit à vie ce n'est
pas conforme aux principes fondamentaux
du droit français l'administration
refuse l'administration
vos gars de fiches et ce avec un autre
fichier que tout le monde connaisse et
le stick le système de traitement des
infractions constatées
c'est avec on sait que les dénoncer ce
nom alors oui je sais pas qui à
l'antériorité il n'y a pas de
susceptibilité d'auteur aménagé pour
être tout à fait franc je pense que les
avocats n'ont pas été mauvais sur la
dénonciation du stick et sur le
caractère erroné de plus de 50% des
informations qui sont portées
demain vous ou moi on veut contester ce
qui a marqué dans le stic sur nos c'est
que personne va bouger et personne n'a
bougé et personne ne va vous aider à
faire votre recours pour corriger les
excès et ses mais on est même au delà
d'excès on est dans l'erreur manifeste
de skis marquée dans le stic par
exemple
demain on vous reproche d'avoir bousculé
un policier samedi d'accord vous le
reproche tellement qu'on vous placent en
garde à vue et vous arrivez devant le
tribunal correctionnel et
puis le tribunal correctionnel dit c'est
pas vrai il et les faits ne sont pas
établis il n'a pas bousculé monsieur
vous êtes relaxé rentrez chez vous vous
rendrez chez vous vous
[raclement de gorge]
avez une déclaration officielle de
l'absence totale de culpabilité dans les
faits qui vous sont reprochés ce avec la
mention au stic a bousculé samedi elle
va rester et et vous pouvez cavale et
faire quelques tours de périph avant
d'arriver à la faire supprimer cette
tension voilà c'est ça le fichage
généralisé parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que la prochaine
fois la prochaine manif où vous allez et
parce que vous avez été repérés parce
que vous êtes une personnalité et ses
ondes il faudrait quand même qu'on le
fasse tomber lui un jour il dit
tellement de mal de nous et
après ça le juge qui va recevoir le truc
et qu'est ce qui va se passer il va dire
il y avait enfin on vous a déjà reproché
c'est fait ouais mais j'ai été innocenté
mais voilà
c'est ça le fichage généralisé le
fichage généralisé ça veut dire que sur
un sujet où on a déjà statué l'ère
du soupçon et du reproche continuent à
peser sur vous et bien pour en venir à
une de vos préoccupations initiales qui
étaient celles de l'état de droit et à
laquelle j'adhère ci
voulait précisément ça dans un état de
droit ce n'est pas acceptable et
précisément dans un état de droit le
pouvoir exorbitant que s'arrogent
l'administration de conserver en mémoire
une vérité qui n'est que la sienne qui
n'est même pas la vérité judiciaire ben
ça ce n'est pas acceptable
un
fichier ce fichier est ce qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est bien mais moi
j'attends le jour où on va avoir un type
qui va nous dire sous le sous l'angle de
l'impératif de la sécurité de tout le
monde qu'il faut arbitrairement enfermer
les fichiers s est
là on va avoir la qualité des débats à
l'assemblée nationale on va voir comme
d'habitude qui aura le courage de se
lever pour dire que un fichier ce n'est
pas une vérité établie et qui va suivre
de façon panurgique l'élan général en
n'osant pas se lever bas mais on en
revient à notre conversation dia un
instant sur la qualité des débats
publics et sur ne nous exonérons pas a
appris facile et sur la responsabilité
commune que nous avons de la qualité de
ce débat parce que si un jour nous
devions sortir de l'état de droit pour
verser dans l'arbitraire étatique ce
sera une faillite collective nous aurons
tous contribué c'est
pour ça qu'il faut réveiller les
consciences et produits prise de
conscience les préconisations ton chien
st je
sais ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'on
fait une grève de la faim on
voit d'abord je pense que tous les
moyens sont bons vous adopter celui que
vous dicte votre conscience moi j'ai pas
l'âme de raul castro ça n'est pas moi je
ne compte pas dicter aux gens la façon
dont ils doivent militer ce dont je peux
vie vous témoigner c'est de ma
détermination à méditer et à militer
pour que l'on reste dans une société qui
respecte les libertés individuelles qui
respecte les libertés publiques
notamment la liberté d'expression
et
contrairement à ce qu'on tente à nous
faire accroire
ce n'est pas une préoccupation de
militants baudot et ce n'est pas non
plus une préoccupation contraire aux
impératifs de sécurité je vais même vous
dire plus l'insécurité
c'est l'abandon de nos valeurs parce que
l'insécurité c'est précisément laisser
aux ennemis de la civilisation
le fait que nous adoptions leur façon de
penser en contestant la liberté publique
et la liberté individuelle pas
c'est l'abandon de nos valeurs qui nous
met en danger parce qu'après ça qu'est
ce qui va faire la différence entre nous
et nos ennemis rien
donc pas vous à contre le fait qu'on
envoie des assassins en afrique pour
aller buter des terroristes ou des
choses comme ça mais la seule chose qui
nous différencie d'eux seydou loi et
d'autres tribunaux et nous avons nos
juges mais bcc doivent trouver façon
internet ces deux pôles r d'autan pire
que les boues rouges et cela doit tout
autant être plus beaucoup plus beau non
mais attendez il ya il ya deux choisis à
la guerre qui obéit à ses propres lois
on
est dans une situation violente il faut
voir il ya deux choses dans votre
question faut voir sur le théâtre des
opérations comment on se comporte il
faut voir aussi comment on se comporte
chez nous face à la menace moi en tant
qu'avocat au barreau de paris je vais à
des audiences à paris il m'arrive
d'aller défendre certains de mes
confrères qui sont incarcérés à istanbul
parce qu'on les accuse parce qu'ils ont
défendu un terroriste de complicité de
terrorisme ça c'est le dossier kurde
c'est autre chose mais restons déjà sur
ce qui fait la spécificité de la société
française ici dans son oeuvre de justice
un
terroriste c'est quoi c'est quelqu'un
qui frappa l'aveuglent parce qu'il fait
une guerre de pauvres mais
il frappa l'aveuglent l'assaut
était française si elle se met à frapper
à la veulent ça veut dire qu'elles
adoptent des comportements terroristes
les
victimes du terrorisme elles ont parlé
que l'occasion de s'expliquer
contradictoirement avant d'être puni
nous
on donne aux terroristes l'occasion de
s'expliquer avant de le punir c'est ça
la différence dans les deux cas il ya de
la violence savez quand vous prononcer
une décision d'incarcération avec une
peine de sûreté c'est violent c'est
dans la différence c'est que la personne
a pu se défendre et bien si demain on
agit comme ceux qui ne donnent pas à
ceux qui vont frapper l'occasion de se
défendre ça veut dire que nous devenons
com comment va le système carcéral
français mal mal
parce que à mon avis pour une raison de
fond d'abord c'est pas un débat
populaire donc les politiques refusent
de s'en emparer parce qu'ils risquent de
perdre des électeurs le grand drame des
prisonniers c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
prescripteurs de vote oui donc leurs
conditions a dit fehr et plus vous
cherchez à comprendre comment améliorer
leurs conditions - vous êtes populaire
et c'est un grand tort parce que ça
aussi c'est une source d'insécurité
parce que quand la prison est
criminogène ça veut dire que vous mettez
en danger vos concitoyens à la sortie si
vous refusez de vous en occuper la
deuxième chose c'est que aujourd'hui nos
prisons ne sont pas des seuls espaces de
privation de liberté ce sont devenus des
espaces de privation de dignité et
bien en cela nous nous plaçons là encore
en dehors de tout le corpus de valeurs
qui nous porte il
ya un travail remarquable moi je vous
invite à vous y reporter c'est
l'observatoire international des prisons
ma consoeur delphine boizel vise tous
les sujets relatifs à la politique
carcérale avec tous les autres membres
de l'oit et si vous voulez avoir une
idée objective qui plus est car on les
accuse souvent d'être partisan mais les
chiffres et les cas qui sont posées sont
totalement objectif les préconisations
pour améliorer le système moi je suis
tout à fait en ligne avec l'oip on
arrive bientôt à la fin notre interview
de vidy
est ce que vous voyez des choses à
rajouter pour
améliorer ou jeu pour parler de rajouter
non si vous voulez il faut forer
faudrait qu'on lance à un colloque ce
que je peux vous dire c'est un vous
remercier de m'avoir invité très
sincèrement n'y voyez pas une clause de
cession d'un muscle ou pas j'ai regardé
j'ai regardé garde quand même un
entretien avec daniel schneidermann que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement intéressant
j'ai regardé david koubbi que j'ai
trouvé très bon ce que vous jour et et
saluons le bien amicalement si
voulez je pense puisque je conclus sur
ses remerciements que l'immense avantage
de
ce que vous proposez non c'est
précisément de laisser à les changes de
la pensée aux véhicules de la pensée le
temps de s'installer et d'être exprimées
aujourd'hui beaucoup de désaffection
vis-à-vis de nos institutions je pense
par exemple pour revenir à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur les avocats et
la participation aux élections à venir
sont le fait d'un mépris de l'exercice
qui ne laisse pas de place à la pensée
je pense moi qu'on peut réformer les
choses que pour ça on a besoin d'un élan
que ça mérite à tout le moins d'être
tentée et d'être porté ce nouvel élan et
par conséquent là où je vous suis
d'autant plus reconnaissant de votre
invitation c'est que d'une manière
générale et la volonté des avocats s'est
dit dit dit collaborer de façon beaucoup
plus large que leur seul périmètre
professionnel c'est d'avoir une place
sociétal qui soient utiles bon et d'une
manière générale si on multiplie ses
occasions de connaître qui est autrui de
démystifier un certain nombre de chose
de mieux connaître la pensée et donc
après ça on adhère on n'adhère pas on
critique positivement négativement et
encore heureux mais au moins on sait de
quoi on parle et on arrête d'être dans
le slogan est la caricature et pour ça
merci est-ce
que vous avez trois livres un conseiller
notre communauté alors
trois livres bon il faut lire tout
elisée reclus évidemment mais écoutez
là de richard capucins ski
et ben mes
voyages avec hérodote
et puis ces
deux livres que moi qui m'ont beaucoup
marqué c'est épatant c'est voir comment
un système totalitaire produit la pensée
comment on peut s'en émanciper comment
et puis c'est le voyage c'est la
découverte c'est merveilleux et
puis un livre que
j'aime bien quand je redescends chez moi
dans les pyrénées reprendre une fois par
an c'est manon lescaut de l'abbé prévost
parce que c'est bon de rêver avant
dernière question parce que c'est une
question que j'ai omis la justice à
plusieurs vitesses existe toujours bien
sûr fait comme étant des vous venez de
parler de l'arbitrage voilà vous avez
les moyens d'une justice rapide où vous
ne les avez pas je
vais vous dire moi ce qui me dérange le
plus dans la lenteur de la justice c'est
l'absence totale de prise en compte du
message social il
faut quand on pose une question si on
veut avoir confiance dans le système que
la réponse à la question ne viennent pas
de façon dogmatique lointaine est
tardive 1
dernière question qu'on blessé c'est une
question d'heure c'est une bouteille à
la mer dont s'est laissé une bouteille à
la mer sur internet un conseil pour les
jeunes générations un
conseil ça serait de vous dire que la
conversation que nous venons d'avoir
peut vous paraître comporter des aspects
très sombre emparez-vous
des derniers espaces de liberté qui
existent nous
avons nous la chance de vivre libres
dans un pays libre et bien entretenu la
flamme de liberté qui anime ce qui nous
rassemble afin de vous remercier
définitivement une autre question
d'interdiction de tomber faut-il mettre
des citoyens dans le législatif et
l'exécutif comme il se fait dans les
cours d'assises vous
voulez parler du tirage au sort
peut-être c'est ça en réalité
alors vous savez que le projet de loi la
visent à évacuer justement le citoyen en
créant le tribunal criminel
départemental
raison pour laquelle j'y suis
farouchement opposé
j'ai trouvé très surprenante les
commentaires justement sur les réseaux
sociaux des derniers arrêts d'assises il
ya des choses très étonnante qui
circulent y compris de la part de
populiste c'est à dire de gens qui
devraient être assez favorable au fait
que la justice soit rendue au nom du
peuple français ça fait partie des
mystères des contradictions humaines que
je vous en rajoutez vous réitérer mes
remerciements carbon danseuse merci
[musique]